i have to say that you guys are the
buddy cop duo i never knew i needed but
i now love so dearly so thank you for
gifting me with that oh good thank you
what did each of you most enjoy about
that dynamic between your characters oh
yeah
i loved it dude like i really i don't
know we really had a good time
and like even like especially down time
especially like time between that like
when when we weren't shooting just like
it was a long shoot we were out in
calgary for six months yeah and we had a
lot of stuff to do together and like
it was it would have been
interminably impossible to get through
without gill
messing around with me between between
takes and me knitting
and reminding of our love of each other
yeah it was it was a really sweet time
and creating the dynamic was really fun
like gil is a really easy to love guy
generally so that's the access point for
me
um and also he's a you know
astrologically speaking he's a cancer
and i'm a leo and that just is a really
good match they are they are the mother
and the father of the zodiac and uh we
are
it's just a good vibe generally wouldn't
you say
i would say
as you would say
it's been said
so there was no like you know feelings
of torture gill toward andrew you didn't
like you know
want to strangle him in between scenes
at all was this was this also working
for you as well
oh no i i don't think we had any of that
kind of contention
you know i'm saying i mean if you don't
try to make it i mean for as dark as the
material is if you don't try to find
some lightness with it in between the
scenes it's just gonna it's just gonna
bury you yeah that's right yeah gil your
character is skeptical at best of these
people who seem to just sort of blindly
hand themselves over to their belief
he's also the one that made me laugh at
some of his more sarcastic comments so
what was it like to find that balance so
that he's never crossing a line with how
he treats people but he is also never
fully just accepting what they say
um i guess it's probably kind of the dry
nature of bill taba which is you know
kind of essentially myself as well um
[Music]
but it's it's a tricky territory it's a
maneuver
you know um especially in the
circumstances we're doing with a
different culture something that he's
not part of
of but the the realistic uh emotional
uh expression about you know i i see
what's going on we're playing this this
little scenario or we're playing these
roles
you with this culture and then me coming
with the confidence of mine
so i think it's just a little levity
that he has to maybe um have for himself
to continue the job he does
andrew your experience with this story
really defines the trajectory that your
career has been on for the last bit of
time you went from reading this book and
wondering who might adapt it to
establishing yourself enough as an actor
that when it did get adapted you get a
call from the likes of ron howard and
brian grazer so what is that like as an
actor to be in a position where you can
get a call like that and you're given an
opportunity to be a part of a project
that you were already passionate about
yeah i mean it's a
privileged position and uh
you know when i read the book i was
23 i want to say 24
and you know i was
just you know struggling actor and
trying to trying to get work and trying
to book auditions and
you know uh trying to avoid having to
take another job and and yeah and then
cut to now yeah it's it's it's odd i
have to say it's you know i don't take
it for granted i find it very humbling
that
you know dustin lance black and and and
the producers thought that i could be a
service in this role and to
to help this um this project see the
light of day and i'm very grateful i i
always just have to give thanks and be
grateful and
and you know
not take any credit for it um
particularly it's just um how how how
the dice have fell and yeah i've worked
hard but also you know there's there's a
great deal of good fortune in there as
well but yeah it's surreal and and
because i think we all as
artists want to just make things that we
feel passionate about and this book
is something that i felt just incredibly
passionate about since i first read it
so the idea of being a and and then
doing it with this ensemble like i
haven't been a part of such an ensemble
cast in so long where it's just a real
a real team you know uh
and we're all cogs in in the wheel that
are unnecessary to make the experience
whole so yeah it's been
it was hard work and as gil
said you know
we had to make it as fun and joyful as
possible in between um scenes because
we couldn't sustain that kind of
heaviness
and thank god it was a a group of people
that were so
you know a good good good spirited they
were telling the story together even the
ones that played and especially like you
know wyatt and and sam who were playing
the you know those kind of
very very dark dark uh roles doing very
dark behavior and um thank god they're
they're as good a people as they are
when you play a role like this
i mean this brings up a lot of questions
for your character especially
do you feel like it provides any answers
for you or does it just make you dig
deeper into
your own feelings about these types of
things
yeah i think it's i think it deepens
everything i mean that's the idea of a
story like this it doesn't provide easy
answers but it does provide more more
and more questions and i think
that's maybe one of the uh
allegorical aspects of this story is
that questioning mine in a curious mind
is is vital in order to live in reality
and as soon as we stop questioning as
soon as we enter the realm of certainty
we enter a very narrow point of view
that makes us do things and
that that are that are um
incredibly dark and evil
um
and and so i i think the more
questioning the better and i think the
more
expanded our consciousness the better
we're never going to fully
comprehend what the meaning of life is
and i think that's vital to know you
know that we're that we never get there
and as soon as someone
you know conv has convinced themselves
or has been convinced that they have
answers they have
you know
you know rock-solid answers
that will lead them to a fundamentalist
extremist way of being
we're in real trouble as a species and
evidently we're in real trouble as a
species that's yeah
gil what do you think your character was
doing when we don't see him what did you
think he was up to in his off time
[Laughter]
leading questions
yeah
i
i think that um he's probably one of the
watching those crime shows you know
2020
getting tips on
how to investigate
just watching youtube
just like how do i um
that's how i hold the gun and that's how
i turn a corner
well thank you guys i appreciate you
talking to me about this i feel like
there are endless conversations about
this show so thank you thank you